[Musique]
allô allô
à la télé les journaux tout le monde ah
le truc mais oui ce matin je suis allé
au pressing mais attends mais tout le
monde en parle
ah oui en parler aussi lui aussi il en
parle ça veut dire que tout le monde en
parle
tout le monde en parle le résultat parce
que tout le monde en parle
bienvenue sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle vous connaissez le
principe tout le monde en parle alors
tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez Laurent magie le voici
[Applaudissements]
les gens sont gentils ou alors tu les as
bien briefés
non non on n'aura pas dit de t'appeler
un chauffeur de salle quand même qui
vous a dit d'applaudit pas du tout
je t'aime
bon alors Laurent de tous les soirs
c'est quoi ce bordel de 21h à 23h
tu es venu deux fois déjà moi je suis
déjà allé deux fois
j'ai entendu Jack Lang le soir super
émission super émission type très cool
très cultivé bizarrement pour un ancien
ministre de la Culture
bachelotière il a décommandé je l'ai au
téléphone il m'a dit je ne peux pas
venir dans une émission qui s'appelle
comme ça je vais d'écouter on peut
changer le nom
si tu te sens pas bien tu te barres toi
et puis c'est son entourage qui lui a
déconseillé de venir alors à part ça il
y a le court-métrage que vous avez fait
qui s'appelle hot-dog qui a eu le prix
de la au festival de l'Alpe d'Huez et la
mention du jury jeudi et la mention du
jury bien merci Laurent
[Applaudissements]
mis à part Laurent Baffie
les Robins des bois
Enrico Macias
Christophe Dominici
et Bruno Pelletier
elle nous accueillons tout de suite Anne
de Bellini
Anne bonsoir bonsoir c'est une entrée
très remarquée aussi alors un autre
journal tous les jours sur Canal de
12h40 à 13h40 avec Philippe Gildas
Jérôme Bonaldi et sur Comédie une
émission qui s'appelle slip ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire sans limite
incorruptibles les professionnels
à 19h voilà alors vous êtes avec nous on
est ravi c'est la première fois qu'on
vous reçoit ça me fait plaisir mais
quand je vous vois je regrette que ce
soit hein
non je peux pas être trop sexiste parce
qu'après je me fais allumer avantage
dehors avantage dehors alors vous savez
qu'il y a une tradition dans cette
émission c'est que chaque semaine on
diffuse les meilleurs moments de la
semaine précédente ça s'appelle tout le
monde en a parlé
vous étiez sympa comme copains
parce que vous payez même les locations
de ski et payer le mini bar aussi
dernier coup de main
je comprends pourquoi il perd toujours
PSG
dernier coup de blues
si tu veux pas certaines choses à ta
copine fais-le sinon aller ravoir
ailleurs ou bien aux gens
bisous je dis bisous
en bas
il vous demande d'influencer
Roland Dumas c'est pas tout à fait
l'histoire mais c'est pas influencé en
tout cas moi j'essaie d'employer des
mots voilà
moi aussi je vais me faire comme ça tu
as vu les j'ai pas vu mais j'ai écouté
de vendre
c'est un peu chaud
par le sexe
c'est un mot que j'entends de temps en
temps ça veut dire quoi faire le
Guillaume c'est un mec je sais pas c'est
ça peut être une pomme sur la tête
à Guillaume qui rap
parce que attends
c'est pas parce que j'habite dans le 16
et que mes parents me donnent 10000
francs par mois que j'ai pas le droit de
crier l'injustice pourquoi vous m'avez
pas laissé traîner avec des Arabes et
des Noirs c'est à cause de vous tu vois
non parce que vous êtes restés puceau
jusqu'à 22 ans oui mais oui jusqu'à quel
âge a été puceau de moi
ah ah normal très très en trésor normal
mesure 22
il avait 13 ans
qui arrivent à s'auto sucer
la question c'est le jeu de la vérité
Fleury Merogis j'ai pas eu trop eu le
temps de penser à ça mais pourquoi pas
voilà c'était tout le monde en a parlé
le best of de la semaine dernière
ah mais peut-être bonsoir c'est vrai que
vous avez fait votre casting pour Canal+
vous étiez fait défriser les cheveux
c'est quand même des filles à cheveux
lisses qui peuvent faire ah comme ça et
moi non alors j'ai dit bon j'ai été
acheté du matériel à défrisage j'ai fait
un truc c'était ni fait ni à faire
c'était une espèce de truc alors du coup
j'ai dit ah non donc j'ai fait une queue
de cheval j'ai une mèche comme ça j'ai
revu j'ai vu l'année dernière
cherche des chroniqueurs vous avez
appelé au flanc en fait vous vous
travaillez au revenu français qui est un
journal
économique des interviewiers des grands
patrons et vous êtes allé vous êtes
parti sur sur Canal+ on va regarder
l'émission sur Comédie que les gens
connaissent moins forcément forcément
c'est un endroit qui est simple
symbolisé par une piscine que voilà
piscine des appartements en rond en
rouge la piscine donc je vais dire ça
c'est agréable d'y habiter j'ai et des
palmiers parce que nous sommes quand
même en
California je fais saillant de cette
semaine c'est Michael Michael tout le
monde le déteste il est audio c'est un
Michael qui se remet à sortir
avec Jane qui était son ex-femme alors
mais pour des mauvaises avec qui avec
Jane d'accord Jane symbolise par un cœur
mais c'est pour des mauvaises raisons
parce que Jay il veut rendre jaloux
Richard le styliste qui sort avec Joe la
photographe mais Joe sort avec Richard
parce qu'elle veut rendre jaloux Jack
qui sort avec Chelly mais Shelly chérie
est une en fait une petite j'ai pas
peur de le dire cela marqué là chez lui
il faut la rayer de sa mémoire parce
qu'elle a volé de l'argent ses pauvre
Jack et c'est Matt mat c'est le de
la série en font assez mal qui l'a
découvert et qu'il a dit à un du coup
avec avec Jack et chez lui sorte plus du
tout ça bref là au troisième étage il y
a comment il s'appelle ben c'est ben
c'est un mandat alors Amanda celle qui
possède Melrose Place elle est pétée
elle fait rien juste elle bouge ses
cheveux elle met des robes ok ensuite
nous avons Billy Billy Billy alors Billy
il sort avec Brooke c'est une histoire
étrange il sort avec Brook avant il
sortait avec Alison que je vais mettre
là mais le truc super chelou c'est que
Alison elle sort avec Elec et le père de
Brook qui sort avec Billy donc n'importe
quoi le truc vaguement astueux ça se
passe ma Alison tac elle est enceinte au
début Billy super pas content maintenant
il est content ça va sauf ça fout un peu
la merde parce que Billy Alison il
s'aime quand même toujours voilà ça
s'appelle swipe et c'est tous les
samedis soir à 19h sur la chaîne Comédie
voilà est-ce que vous connaissez
Mouna Ayoub
une femme qui a eu un destin absolument
extraordinaire elle a démarré avec un
chat d'or et maintenant elle a des
milliers de drogues
bonsoir
Anne de pétrini
Canal+ comédie Laurent Baffie Europe 2
Laurent
les aventures
et on peut dire les mycoses des petits
problèmes
je te laisse entre les mains de Thierry
alors on va d'abord on va parler de ce
que vous faites aujourd'hui en termes de
de caritatives en termes d'art et avant
je vais quand même raconter votre vie
donc vous êtes libanaise chrétienne
né à Beyrouth et vous aviez 17-18 ans
quand la guerre du Liban a éclaté vous
êtes venu en France d'abord dans le sud
de la France et en 76 vous vous
retrouvez à Paris à la Sorbonne
sans beaucoup d'argent
une chambre de bonne non chauffée avec
un lavabo un lit vous travaillez d'abord
dans une pizza ça c'est un destin
champignon absolument absolument
extraordinaire vous serez dans une pizza
et ensuite dans un restaurant libanais
de 8 heures du soir à 3h du matin et le
matin il fallait quand même prendre le
métro à 7h pour être en cours à 8h donc
c'est assez courageux vos parents vous
envoient à 300 francs par mois et au
resto dans le resto vous gagnez quand
même
on faisait que le pourboire
vous aviez du succès avec les hommes
parce que c'est une très jolie femme et
vous avez du succès avec les hommes
depuis l'âge de 14 ans déjà sur la plage
à Beyrouth vous aperceviez qui vous qui
vous regardez et en fait vous aviez
aucune envie d'épouser un étudiant du
même âge vous avez pas envie de
travailler 20 ans pour acheter une
maison à la fin c'est ça
c'est une vie qui vous tentait pas mais
c'est pas j'avais absolument aucune
envie de me marier tout court tout ce
que je voulais c'est bosser travailler
dénicher mon mon bac ou ma maîtrise et
travailler pour pour soutenir et se
venir aux besoins de ma famille tout ce
que je voulais c'est arrivé tout à fait
par hasard vous aviez pas que vous aviez
épousé un homme qui allait devenir l'un
des hommes les plus riches du monde pour
la dixième fortune du monde un soir vous
voyez un homme entrait dans le
restaurant libanais vous travaillez à
Passy avec une fille blonde avec lui
vous discutez un peu comme vous parlez
arabe il vous demande ce que ce que vous
faites là etc vous comprenez attention
vous vous étiez vous étiez quoi à la
caisse vous étiez vous y a quoi dans ce
restaurant
mat donc je tenais les comptes de du
restaurant je servais quand ils avaient
besoin de services et puis à la fac
quand tout le monde partait on faisait
un peu la fête parce qu'on était
tellement
arriver on avait tellement travaillé
donc
à 8h du matin quand même j'étais
toujours à l'heure plus maintenant
alors donc un soir vous rencontrez cette
homme le lendemain il revient mais sans
la blonde
le lendemain il revient encore avec la
blonde c'est le surlendemain qui revient
sans l'absence et puis après il se met à
venir tous les jours tous les jours
pendant deux semaines
alors il avait 38 ans saoudien musulman
pour vous ça représentait la sécurité
effectivement c'est un homme qui était
même si tu es pas encore très très riche
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui était
déjà dans le monde des affaires non il
était dans le bon des affaires justement
il était en France parce que il signait
son premier contrat très important et
comprenez pas la langue française et moi
je la maîtrisais assez bien et c'est là
que je pense qu'il m'a fait confiance
parce que c'est lui c'est c'était moi
qui avait traduit son premier contrat
est-ce que cet homme vous l'avez aimée
est-ce que ça a été le coup de foudre
comme dans la chanson là va te faire
side où est-ce qu'au contraire vous
dites je vais apprendre à l'aimer
l'amour ça se construit c'est pas
quelque chose qui finalement sa force de
vivre qu'on finit par s'aimer ou alors
simplement il ressemblait au marche
arrière et vous avez craqué tout de
suite
c'était le coup de fou que c'est à dire
que j'étais absolument fasciné par lui
il était il était très intéressant
et toi très intéressé
alors il vous emmène en week-end à
Londres alors là vous aviez vous y
connaissiez Beyrouth vous connaissez
Marcel Aix Paris et c'est tout donc là
vous découvrez Londres et vous mettez à
l'adorais quoi c'est c'est alors pour le
mariage évidemment là ça commence vous
commandez une Europe chez Jean-Louis
Scherrer mais c'est obligé de perdre 10
kilos pour rentrer dedans
et puis elles sont toutes menus comme
vous savez les mannequins et moi je bon
ces baguettes chocolat et beurre tous
les matins
un régime pendant presque trois quatre
semaines pour pouvoir entrer dans le
modèle parce qu'ils avaient pas le temps
de me refaire une autre c'était très dur
ce mariage là ça a commencé ça a
commencé très très mal excusez-moi
alors vous retrouvez en Arabie Saoudite
dans un palais alors je sais pas si
c'est le bon chiffre de 30000 mètres
carrés
quand je suis arrivée c'était pas un
palais c'était une maison que je devais
aménager elle a tout fait ses mains
et puis c'est devenu un palier je pense
que palais sont une princesse
il fallait la princesse non c'est devenu
on l'a fait ensemble quoi pendant 3 ans
on l'a vu
dimanche
ça s'est passé doucement tranquillement
vous n'allez pas croire il y avait pas
de métro mais il y avait un train oh non
après votre votre arrivée donc là bas
lui s'en va à Genève en voyage
d'affaires papa est en voyage d'affaires
sans vous alors il part il vous dit
qu'il s'en va pour une semaine et il
revient à moi après il voulait être seul
tu vois chérie je t'ai jamais fait des
trucs comme ça moi quand même c'est pour
mettre le cadreur
une semaine c'est vrai que c'est pas
terrible quoi et alors vous quand vous
êtes présenté à la famille vous aviez
fait un repas vous l'avez fait tout seul
de vos blanches mains vous faites un
repas et quand vous mettez à table tout
le monde se lève parce qu'ils avaient
fini cette expérience était je pense la
plus difficile parce que d'abord c'était
la première où il fallait connaître tout
le monde et se faire connaître et
c'était un grand choc parce que là je me
sentais pour la première fois de ma vie
alors que j'étais étudiante je voyage et
j'ai fait des jobs et tout seul seul et
boutiner dans cette petite robe dans
cette petite robe Jean-Louis
d'ailleurs pendant presque 6 mois j'ai
mangé mes larmes quoi lui ces voyages se
multiplient je la fais courte parce que
sinon lui c'est voyages se multiplient
et les rumeurs se les rumeurs se
répandent et une bonne amie il y a
toujours des bonnes copines dans ce cas
là une bonne amie libanaise qui vous dit
que votre mari a une affaire avec une
femme à Beyrouth
et alors là ça faut connaître la les
traditions dans ces pays-là
c'est l'anniversaire de vos 7 ans de
mariage vous attendez le retour de votre
mari qui était encore parti en voyage
pendant 2 mois décidément c'était une
habitude et quand il revient il vous
annonce qu'il va se marier
c'est en cas difficile dans les cours
cap difficile c'est connu l'histoire de
l'anniversaire même avec un gâteau
et j'avais ce joli gâteau et j'attendais
j'attendais c'était pour qu'on m'annonce
que mon mari allait se marier parce
qu'il fallait
c'était la tradition après un certain
temps c'est à dire si le mari ne prouve
pas qu'il peut
moi je dis rien je suis une correction
exemplaire moi j'aurais pu dire alors
tout le monde commence à se moquer de
lui comme quoi il est avec la même femme
pendant 7 ans c'est pas possible
à la fois
du roi dans le Diwan je sais pas comment
on appelle ça se moquer de lui comment
il est avec la même femme pendant 7 ans
et donc soit il comme on me voyait pas
parce que j'étais voilée entièrement
donc certains se demandaient elle doit
être sûrement belle des autres dans
cette surement une antiqueineuse
d'autres se disaient oh elle doit elle
doit avoir quelque chose des forces
surnaturelles donc on disait on trouvait
tout pour que voilà ce mariage ne marche
pas et je pense que c'est un peu
pour se prendre une épouse
supplémentaire c'est de dire à sa
première femme écoute chérie tu es très
occupé avec les enfants donc maintenant
j'ai besoin d'une femme plus jeune qui
soit moins occupée avec les enfants
c'est pas mal comme technique
et donc là effectivement bon séparez de
lui donc et vous partez après c'était la
rupture quoi je voulais plus rentrer
ta robe
là je rentrais plus du tout parce que je
faisais j'avais déjà trois enfants voilà
je vais vous faire vous allez voir c'est
la question qui tue
est-ce que vous aviez eu à choisir donc
entre d'une part vivre en Arabie
Saoudite cloîtré avec vos enfants ou
quitter l'Arabie Saoudite et vivre sans
vos enfants est-ce que des fois vous
vous dites pas j'aurais mieux fait de
rester en Arabie Saoudite parce que je
serai toujours avec mes enfants
je me dis ça tous les matins
[Musique]
à tous les matins et tous les matins
quand je parle à mes enfants je leur
demande de me pardonner d'avoir décidé
de partir parce que je ne pouvais plus
être une bonne mère ou je pensais qu'à
la fin je vais devenir une mère folle et
mais je sais aujourd'hui ma force de
résistance était telle que j'aurais pu
rester et d'ailleurs mon fils aîné me
dit jusqu'à présent un moment tu es
parti trop tôt
on allume
merci donc vous dites je ne crois plus à
l'amour c'est quand même grave quand on
vous voit vous êtes jolie vous êtes
riche vous êtes cultivé c'est terrible
ça non
non parce que je suis très occupée c'est
à dire que au moment où je pouvais
croire en l'amour et au moment où
j'étais en Arabie Saoudite je pouvais
avoir tous les allemands les plus beaux
les plus basiques et puis je faisais
rien de mon temps sauf gérer la maison
s'occuper des enfants des Philippins
j'ai dit j'ai passé ma vie avec des
Philippins et des enfants donc vous
développez si vous voulez vraiment
désintérêt total et quand les quand on
me pose la question comment j'ai pu me
conserver physiquement aussi longtemps
et bien je peux vous dire que c'est à
cause de ça
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle mais il faut
pas dormir il faut pas de sexe
et vous dites vous dites je ne me
remarierai pas
ah oui elle est riche maintenant
vous avez jamais rencontré un homme dont
vous vous dites jamais jamais bien après
donc vous partez à New York là c'est une
expérience aussi pas très drôle parce
que les gens voulaient profiter de vous
vous êtes tombés sur une bande de
parasites on peut dire non oui c'est un
peu le cas de toutes les femmes je pense
seul et
il savait qui j'étais beaucoup plus que
moi je ne le savais donc j'étais d'une
naïveté absolument
inacceptable à mon âge disons alors un
jour vous vendez vos bijoux
gagner 60 enfin la vente vous rapporte
62 millions de francs
en deux heures de vente vous en donner
d'ailleurs une grande partie à la
Fondation Pompidou on y reviendra il
émet jamais et
vous achetez le Phocéen
36 millions de francs bateau qui avait
appartenu à l'incola et à Bernard Tapie
il a restauration du fossé à beaucoup de
plus cher que prévu ça coûte une
centaine de millions de francs c'est
quand même 120 millions ce qui fait
quand même le bateau autour de 150
millions quand même alors vous louez ce
bateau combien un million deux un
million 5 la semaine en haute saison il
fait un million 2 la semaine la haute
saison c'est-à-dire Cannes juillet août
en Méditerranée
si on est 3000 si on est 3000 on peut se
le payer à 3000 on peut l'acheter
malheureusement on peut pas être plus
que 12 donc ça fait 1 million deux
divisé par
1200000 balles pour une semaine par
personne
j'avais peur d'être obligé de payer le
vin en plus
de couture vouloir laisser quoi par an 3
millions par an à peu près non
je collectionne la haute couture vous
dites on a tous besoin d'une drogue moi
c'est la haute couture c'est une nuit
pas c'est vrai que c'est une drogue qui
nuit passe une nuit un peu à votre
compte en banque ce que vous dites mais
ça nuit pas il faut travailler plus dur
et faire plus d'argent donc c'est vrai
que vous avez porté votre première robe
à l'âge de 7 ans seulement moi j'étais
un garçon manqué je passais mon temps à
à marcher dans les forêts à lire à
grimper les arbres je passais mon temps
à être seul et c'est peut-être cette
nature là qui m'a aidé à surmonter les
20 ans de solitude en Arabie Saoudite
et c'est vrai qu'il suffirait de 15
femmes comme vous pour que la haute
couture survive alors en juillet 99
vous avez fait une exposition à
Marseille
120 robes vous en avez 1000 de robe non
1140 1140 sur le dixième de votre
collection au Musée de la Mode de
Marseille
c'est une des robes que j'adore c'était
une copie de la robe Coco Chanel
alors
vous êtes
menariaux d'une très bonne cliente de la
maison de la maison Dior et dernièrement
il y a eu je dis pas que c'était un
énorme scandale mais enfin quelque chose
d'assez choquant c'est que John Galliano
a fait une collection SDF c'est à dire
qu'il est habillé les enfin il a fait
une collection de haute couture
inspirait des habits de SDF avec des
bouteilles accrochées à la ceinture
enfin etc génial
voilà donc c'est la collection de John
Galliano pour pour Dior
alors
ça a pas la vous choquer beaucoup
non moi ça me choque pas moi je trouve
que c'est une c'est une expression comme
tout autre c'est une expression
artistique
vous donnez beaucoup d'argent aux
oeuvres caritatives quand on vous dit
pourquoi vous le dites vous dites je
décide de le dire pour mes enfants parce
que vos enfants vous reprochent des fois
votre votre sens des affaires votre
indépendance votre liberté et donc vous
vous pensez que c'est mieux de le dire
de leur montrer qu'avec l'argent
finalement on peut faire aussi des
choses utiles d'abord il me reproche mon
départ
et puis je ne suis pas avec
j'adore les enfants j'adore les miens
j'adore les enfants je voudrais toujours
faire quelque chose pour les enfants
je compense si vous voulez ce manque en
embrassant en prenant dans mes bras
d’autres enfants mais surtout en les
aidant et en les éduquant parce que
l'éducation la culture fait énormément
de différence je pense que si 90% des
enfants en Arabie Saoudite sont éduqués
de la même manière que les enfants en
France et que les enfants aux États-Unis
le monde serait là-bas en tout cas
serait beaucoup plus heureux le 29
février 2000 aura lieu donc une vente à
Christine dont les bénéfices vous les
donnerez à l'atelier des enfants du
Centre Pompidou à Beaubourg que vous
parrainez pour pour trois ans si je
donne aujourd'hui si vous voulez au
musée surtout le pour les enfants de
l'atelier des enfants c'est parce
qu'encore je pense que si j'avais pu
moi-même profiter de cette culture
artistique pendant 20 ans je pense avoir
être encore une personne beaucoup plus
intéressante si je vous raconte ce soir
c'est très intéressant on va regarder
des et des œuvres d'art que vous aimez
magnéto Serge
le Cyclope m'a beaucoup intéressé parce
que quand j'étais enfant on disait
toujours dessine un homme qui te fait
peur et c'était toujours le Cyclope
pendant toute ma vie j'ai dessiné un
homme avec un soleil une seule bouche et
quand je suis arrivée à Milly-la-Forêt
l'année dernière j'étais il a vu je
l'avais vu ce Cyclope qui était avec moi
depuis
et j'étais très intéressée par le
travail
l'esprit très ouvert très avant-garde
d'ailleurs c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle j'ai voulu j'ai quitté un homme
si riche pour pouvoir m'exprimer très
bien
maintenant
comme dans votre vie
vous avez eu des hauts et les bas on va
faire une interview à peine d'âme vous
savez il y a un truc ici c'est que
pendant le jingle on ne bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce que vous préférez en vous la chose
que vous préférez en vous ma franchise
la chose que vous détestez en vous
le plus grand moment de votre vie
le premier enfant que j'ai eu
et le pire quand il était devenu malade
quand on m'a appris qu'il avait la
leucémie c'était à Paris d'ailleurs
ce qui vous plaît le plus dans la vie
l'océan la mer ce qui vous emmerde le
plus dans la vie
les hommes
on a aucune chance
votre plus gros coup de frais votre
meilleur affaire vous ayez jamais faite
quand Coca-Cola est arrivé à Riad
Coca-Cola vous savez était interdit à
rien parce qu'ils avaient une fabrique
en Israël tout ce qui est fabriqué en
Israël est interdit en Arabie Saoudite
et du coup je me lève matin je lis le
journal et je vois que Coca-Cola est
arrivé en Arabie Saoudite par
l'intermédiaire d'un ami à mon ex à mon
ex-mari alors j'appelle cet ami bien sûr
je suis fan donc je suis rien il ne
m'écoute pas il veut dire
alors j'appelle un autre ami un Libanais
qui habite en Amérique je lui dis tu
peux s'il te plaît m'acheter des actions
tant que tu peux jusqu'à quand tu peux
mettre j'ai dit jusqu'à presque 500000
dollars en trois mois c'est devenu un
million 500 000 dollars
c'est la plus belle affaire que j'ai une
vraie pomme d'affaires et votre plus
votre plus grosse paire c'est quoi votre
plus mauvaise affaire
si vous fait le plus rire dans la vie
qui me fait rire vous c'est gentil
dommage si vous fait le moins rire
la maladie et la souffrance des enfants
ce que vous avez plus sexy en vous
[Rires]
pourquoi jusqu'à 2h par jour bah c'est
ma thérapie ça change tous les matins je
vais téléphone vendait acheter vendez
merci au rallume
[Applaudissements]
rester avec nous je pense que je m'amuse
tellement vous êtes très bien et très
heureux de vous avoir surtout que
maintenant on accueille un grand
écrivain français Max Gallo
bonsoir bonsoir Laurent Baffie
alors Napoléon mesurait un mètre 59 de
Gaulle 1 m 93 et vous un mètre 93 aussi
non c'est ça ouais
ça vous aide à cacher aux autres votre
timidité vous impressionnez alors que
vous êtes dans l'état d'esprit d'un nain
vous trouvez quand même c'est pas votre
genre ça c'est humilité non c'est une
humilité cachée
parce que franchement en fait en
question non vous êtes plutôt ce qu'on
pourrait appeler aujourd'hui un géant
pas de la littérature mais de l'édition
en tous les cas
vous sortez quoi je sais pas comme
combien de livres par an depuis quelques
années entre Napoléon
deux ou trois par an ils vendent très
très bien d'ailleurs vous avez fait 70
livres
alors vous on parlait du destin de Mouna
Ayoub qui est assez extraordinaire
passionnant parce que bon elle vient
très beau livre à écrire absolument mais
la connaissons elle le fera elle-même
déjà ça ressemble
menait à jamais fait ça
mais vous aussi vous avez un destin
extraordinaire parce que finalement
fils d'immigré italien vivant à Nice
marié un Libanais légitime non
malheureusement en Arabie Saoudite
votre père alors normalement vous avez
dit que votre père était employé de
banque mais mon père était électricien
avait travaillé dans une banque il y a
des moments où bon j'ai un peu laissé
passer ça comme ça j'ai dit employé de
banque c'était plus simple c'était trop
compliqué
vous votre premier diplôme c'est un
diplôme de mécanicien ajuster c'est bien
c'est une successeur storique vous allez
tracer de ma vie c'est bien ici avec
Catherine Barma c'est le destin des gens
c'est vrai c'est la biographie des gens
l'histoire a fait éruption l'Histoire
avec un grand âge sa éruption dans votre
vie quand vous avez vu deux résistants
pendus à lampadaire est-ce que c'est
vrai ça oui non c'est vrai je crois que
pour un enfant mais ça devait être
pareil pour les enfants libanais pour
les enfants aujourd'hui du Kosovo
un enfant reçoit la guerre comme une
tragédie qui peut le mutiler et en même
temps je crois qu'il voit la guerre
comme un grand jeu c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire à tous les instants il
y a quelque chose d'inédit on voit des
soldats qui passent on voit des on voit
des avions qui bombardent et puis
brusquement on est face à la tragédie et
moi j'ai vu le 25 juillet 1944 j'avais
une douzaine d'années j'ai vu comme ça
pendre à deux lampadaires de résistance
qu'on a fait monter sur une c'est pas
gay mais autant le dire qu'on a fait que
les Allemands ont fait monter sur des
toits de camionnettes et puis la
camionnette est partie ils sont restés
pendus alors vous commencez à écrire à
l'âge de 16 ans et à 22 ans un peu
problème de classe sociale vous hésitez
un an avant d'entrer à la Sorbonne à
l'harmonie italienne directement elle
était à Aix elle a dit non moi c'est la
Sorbonne pourquoi vous hésitiez vous
étiez c'est pas pour moi il y avait
c'était tellement impressionnant enfin
impressionnant comme mythologie comme
symbole que la première année
aujourd'hui tout ça est modifié parce
que les étudiants se comptent par
millions donc mais disons que dans les
années 50 la Sorbonne c'était la somme
moi je n'ai pas osé franchir la voûte
avec et à droite il y avait la porte de
la loge de la concierge qui vendait les
programmes je me suis arrêté là j'ai
acheté la j'ai acheté le programme et
puis j'ai en fonction du programme j'ai
évidemment étudié alors aujourd'hui bon
vous écrivez vous faites plus qu'écrire
d'ailleurs on verra un petit peu plus
tard ce que vous avez fait avant mais là
pour le moment vous faites plus
qu'écrire vous dites je ne sais plus
faire que ça finalement donc vivez avec
un pied dans l'imaginaire un pied dans
la un pied dans la réalité alors là
c'est incroyable ça va fait flipper
beaucoup de gens ça Max Gallo écrit
quand même 10 heures par jour 15
feuillets par jour
samedi et dimanche compris 6 heures de
sommeil les 23h30 oui très bien vous
avez pas beaucoup de mérite parce que
vous dites quand j'écris pas j'ai des
migraines et des sifflements dans les
oreilles donc de toute façon donc c'est
devenu une seconde nature voilà alors
maintenant on va parler de votre livre
voilà donc miles galop bleu blanc rouge
c'est une trilogie c'est le premier tome
qui s'appelle Mariella
alors c'est pour résumer la situation
c'est deux siècles d'histoire de France
à travers le destin de siphanie oui oui
c'est une manière de c'est tout le monde
connaît sans connaître l'histoire de
France parce que l'histoire de France
c'est bon c'est un programme scolaire
c'est ennuyeux etc or pour moi
l'histoire est peut-être à cause de ce
que vous avez rappelé parce que pour moi
ça d'abord été ce que j'ai vu avec des
yeux d'enfants pour moi l'histoire c'est
essentiellement des gens vivants donc là
mon projet c'était de faire revivre en
racontant les vies de six personnages
dans les années au moment où ça commence
pour la France contemporaine
c'est-à-dire au moment de la Révolution
française et puis de suivre ces familles
jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais sans sans
théorie bien alors les personnages
principaux Maximilien forestier soldat
de la révolution qui va terminer
maréchal l'Empire et Guillaume du cerf
lui c'est le de Jenny quoi
il fait de l'argent je dirais
malgré ma voisine ou à cause de ma
voisine ce serait prudent dans ce
domaine mais il fait de l'argent il fait
de l'argent voilà thorignan préfère
faire couper la tête que renoncer à ses
idées et finalement ce que vous dites
c'est il y a deux choses moi qui m'ont
intéressé dans votre bouquin la première
notion c'est la notion de transbordement
c'est-à-dire ce moment où l'argent passe
d'une classe sociale à une autre et
finalement où des gens des bourgeois et
des des
parvenus finalement achètent des
châteaux achètent des choses avec des
enchères truquées donc c'est bien sûr on
vit dans des sociétés aujourd'hui par
exemple en France une société stable
chacun est plus ou moins à sa place il y
a des réussites rapides puis imaginez
que tout ça comme ce verre tombe par
terre et se casse non aujourd'hui il a
l'air assez solide
tombe par terre et se casse et ben il y
a des gens qui vont prendre les bons
morceaux et d'autres qui vont au
contraire avoir un morceau de verre dans
le pied et la Révolution française est
pendant au fond une cinquantaine
d'années en France ça et ça ça a été des
femmes qui essayaient de sauver leur
tête à épousant officier républicains ça
a été officier républicain qui aux
enchères achetaient un château ça donc
été un transbordement vous avez employé
le mot un transbordement de fortune un
peu comme par exemple puis tout ça n'a
rien de mystérieux comment Russie quand
le communisme était fondé il y a eu un
transbordement de fortune de pouvoir la
deuxième chose dont vous parlez aussi à
travers ce premier tome c'est
vous dites les girouettes vous dites en
1820 et paru un dictionnaire des
girouettes c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement
les gens qui ont vécu cette période ont
été obligés de changer d'avis ont été
obligés de changer de position parce que
de toute façon les régimes changent
tellement vite que ont commencé avec la
position 36 15 code
[Applaudissements]
Momoa vous lui faites un évêque
non vous dites c'est une époque où les
gens finalement étaient obligés d'une
certaine façon de changer d'avis parce
que
vous aussi vous avez changé d'avis ça
m'est arrivé oui non mais avec moi avec
vous je me souviens très bien oui tout à
fait avec moi je me souviens c'était une
émission sévère c'était
un livre qui s'appelait Louis vin un
livre disons pas défendant la monarchie
mais montrant l'actualité de l'idée
monarchique à la fin du 20e siècle et
vous m'avez attaqué mais d'une façon
terrible vous m'avez j'ai eu le
sentiment d'être attaqué d'une façon
vraiment vous avez été d'une méchanceté
d'une habileté perfide insupportable en
disant d'ailleurs il avait fait le
plateau je crois que ça s'est jamais
produit c'est pas le genre de la maison
c'est jamais produit apostrophe chaque
fois que je parlais j'étais sifflé et
chaque fois qu'il parlait il était
applaudit
parce qu'il avait simplement raison
c'est simplement parce que le plateau a
été fait à sa main quoi
[Musique]
parce que c'est il y a 14 ans donc 14
ans il y a 14 ans il y a prescription
mais je vous disais par exemple je vous
disais par exemple que Louis Louis
xviette le fils de Louis XVI les les
geôliers le faisait boire de l'alcool
pour lui faire avouer que ça qu'il avait
que sa mère n'avait obligé à coucher
avec elle Serge
je ne sais pas si c'est la peine de
débattre je veux dire
est-ce que je peux dire comment prendre
au sérieux
un livre bourré de formule du genre la
monarchie lave plus blanc pourquoi pas
c'est le nouveau stick moi je veux bien
en effet j'ai souri j'ai trouvé ça très
très très intéressant et aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui vous dites
14 ans après la Révolution finalement
est moins mythologique en nous l'a
enseigné
vous avez mis de l'eau dans votre vin
sur la Révolution française max vélo
disons que je suis descendu davantage
dans le tonneau et que j'ai regardé
comment le vin était constitué très bien
voilà alors vous aussi en politique vous
avez pas vous traiter de girouette mais
enfin vous avez quand même évolué vous
avez commencé au jeunesse communiste en
74 entre Ops après la défaite de
Mitterrand élections présidentielles de
80 à 83 vous êtes député PS des
Alpes-Maritimes et ensuite porte-parole
du gouvernement mon roi vous avez été
remplacé par Roland dumaster et en 90
vous commencez à trouver
cette évolution elle est incontestable
c'est vrai que je suis passé d'une
vision on peut dire
marxiste communiste de ma jeunesse qui
était dictée par je ne la recuse pas
parce que quand on veut comprendre le
comportement des gens il faut savoir
d'où ils viennent ce qu'ils sont qui
étaient dicté par le sentiment de
l'humiliation au
à ce qu'il faisait dans la réalité
l'argent qui salit l'argent qui
corrompre
vous connaissez bien non mais
aujourd'hui en tout cas je vous devant
aujourd'hui ma position c'est que je
suis ce qu'on appelle un républicain
comme tant d'autres et surtout je crois
que
il faut conserver à ce qui nous
entourent c'est-à-dire la Nation
française une réalité il faut savoir que
ça a été construit péniblement pendant
des siècles par des gens qui en effet
étaient ceux qui soulaient Le Petit
Louis XV et puis des gens qui au
contraire étaient prêts à mourir pour
essayer de faire évader Louis XVI il y
avait les chouans il y avait et puis il
y avait les bleus et puis il y avait les
blancs tout ça a fait un pays
contradictoire pas toujours satisfaisant
mais un pays qui a un visage singulier
unique même
un exemple brutal il y a eu Jeanne d'Arc
et puis il y a eu un évêque français qui
s'appelait cochon le bien nommé qui a
fait condamner Jeanne d'Arc il tous les
deux Français je suis plutôt du côté de
Jeanne d'Arc il n'empêche que si on veut
comprendre ce que c'est que la France il
faut savoir qu'il y avait aussi l'évêque
et voilà voilà
c'est ça il est
mais je vais beaucoup vous étonner je
peux vous étonner moi j'ai fait ma
première campagne électorale contre
personnage plein de femmes à 2e campagne
électorale contre Jacques Médecin maire
de Nice parce que il y a aussi les
circonstances locales qui vous poussent
à être quelque chose quand vous avez en
face de vous un épouvantail un peu
caricatural c'était la chanson de ma
campagne électorale en 1983 il est
j'adore cette chanson
c'était le pénitencier donc aujourd'hui
Max Gallo bah oui vous êtes proche de
Pasqua de Charles Pasqua enfin je
comprends c'est motivations
vous avez appelé quand même un peu à
voter pour j'ai dit que j'allais voter
pour lui c'est pas appelé
maintenant je parle pour moi seulement
pour moi je suis mon propre porte-parole
je m'arrête à ça et vous dites en
parlant de Philippe de Villiers
d'ailleurs c'est un républicain dans la
morale est exemple de tout reproche tu
sais ce que je pense je pense que c'est
un personnage qui est caricaturé
facilement qui est peut-être un effet
parfois ridicule mais je l'ai eu comme
étudiant quand j'étais prof à Sciences
Po vous voyez le hasard et je sais que
c'est quelqu'un qui est qui est honnête
dans son dans son dans son esprit je
partage pas ses valeurs mais il y a chez
lui une
une fibre patriotique un enracinement
dans le pays que je trouve un peu
vulgaire de critiquer sommairement
mais vous avez tous les symptômes de la
maladie d'Alzheimer
c'est possible attends
je laisse communiste et vous finissez
par encenser les fachos mais vous vous
avez peut-être alors des signes graves
de sénilité précoce
on discutera on en discutera
on en discutera non non c'est beaucoup
engueulé avec Max Gallo et puis
maintenant regarde on est on est passé
16 ans avec galop
bleu blanc rouge premier tome marié là
le pire est à venir Max Gallo le pire
est toujours sûr
comme vous êtes quelqu'un de cultiver
d'intelligent de brillant bien sûr on va
vous faire l'interview nul lumière s'il
vous plaît ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un qui se maîtrise
parfaitement incroyable parce que il n'a
pas signé pendant le carcasse comme ça
il mobile complètement
terrible totalement
l'interview nul vas-y bouge maintenant
vas-y
l'interview nul alors est-ce que vous
préférez c'est comment
c'est toujours des choix c'est votre
surnom alors est-ce que vous préférez
quand on vous appelle le Malraux des
campings ou le Michelet d'hypermarché
c'est équivalence peut-être le Malraux
des campings vous préférez le Malraux
des gens bien dormir sous la tente très
bien ah là tu dois dire un truc
normalement
est-ce que vous préfériez votre père ou
votre mère la mère jusqu'à 14 ans le
père après ah bonne réponse vous
préférez Hitler ou Staline
est-ce que je préfère mourir dans une
chambre à gaz ou dans un chaudron je
sais pas donc c'est des formes de mort
je peux pas choisir entre mes formes de
mort est-ce que vous préférez on se
concentre tout de suite
Hollande ou en Jacques Toubon
je préfère la mort définitive
il faut choisir il faut choisir François
Hollande François Hollande avec vous
François Hollande il est pas tendre avec
moi mais je l'ai vu naître à la
politique car
le hasard fait les choses quand j'ai été
porte-parole du gouvernement il était
mon directeur de cabinet donc c'est je
l'ai vu tout petit en culotte courte
mais il dit des choses sur vous
terribles il dit que à l'époque vous
combattiez médecin à Nice et que
maintenant vous vous retrouvez du côté
de Marchiani dans la
vous le préfet vous voulez toujours être
incarné en françois Hollande bah s'il
faut choisir oui sinon
cette question parce que tout bon
personne n'en veut j'ai jamais vu la
première fois
tu me diras mais pourquoi être réincarné
c'est surtout ça le problème
alors est-ce que vous auriez plus de 10
ans vous donneriez plus de circonstances
atténuantes un jeune qui tape sur des
vieilles ou un vieux qui tape sur des
jeunes un jeune qui tape sur des
vieilles pour leur piquer leur sacs à
main quelle sorte de la poste et
carpention ou un vieux qui se tape des
jeunes le vieux qui le vieux qui stoppe
des jeunes avant d’accord mais je suis
vieux déjà
vous savez que c'est agréable en même
temps alors le mot le plus con pour vous
en amour
c'est merci encore oui oui
ou combien tu peux nous merci merci
merci moustique un amour j'entends bien
est-ce que vous préfériez être coincé
dans un ascenseur avec bernard-heny ou
Philippe solaire
vous voudriez être guillotiné ou pendu
guillotine et disons alors allons-y
guillotinet parce que vous êtes dedans
c'est plus rapide
sûr si vous choisissez
plus propre d'une certaine manière oui
les pendus
respectable même
merci
bien j'accueille maintenant les Robins
des bois
bonjour bonjour
donc Marina Fois c'est ça
de volaille
c'était pas très drôle mais bon
individualité c'est bien d'avoir un
esprit aussi rapide que ça qui
caricature ouais il est très bien je
l'ai vu pendant des années silencieux
comme une carpe mais
on s'était pas croisé là-bas d'ailleurs
je crois pas non
gaillard comme toi
ça c'est vrai surtout quand les mots
sont pas efficaces on est obligé de
passer aux actes évidemment très embêtés
sur la cuisse pour pas qu'il parle ah
ouais c'est pour ça ah bon bah oui
du lundi au vendredi hein et puis alors
la cassette elle est où la cassette je
montre la cassette voilà ça je le fais
bien de montrer la cassette
de la grosse émission exactement à
l'époque où vous étiez dans la Grosse
émission c'est ça c'est à dire pendant 2
ans pendant 2 ans
tous les deux je crois que là oui voilà
c'est des sketchs en fait c'est simple
alors la cassette la promo les Robins
des Bois merci Laurent vous n'êtes que
deux cinq sont décédés dans un instant
beaucoup moins 4 = 2 déjà on apprend des
trucs tu vois
vous savez ce qu'ils font vous les
connaissez pas les Robins des Bois
vous avez attendez ça je ne crois pas le
mec il écrit 10 feuilles ou qu'un
feuillets par jour il se lève à 3h30 du
matin il va te regarder et vous regardez
NPA pas toujours mais ça m'arrive moi
maintenant je dois dire on va regarder
ce qu'ils font les robes là
docteur l'accouchement la femme suffoque
comme il bémol on crée une éclampsie du
bulbe bon taux d'insuline normal rythme
cardiaque excellent blanquette de ce
midi je sais pas j'ai pris des rognons
comment se présente le bébé il se
présente aux élections hello à Michel je
te rappelle qu'on est en urgence c'est
pour ça que je marche vite bien on a pas
le temps de plaisanter et ce qui se
présente par le siège ou pas non non il
se présente par la tête il y a pas de
problème à ce niveau là le souci c'est
qu'il pèse 45 kg c'est beaucoup pour un
bébé oui on est où ici là on est dans
les coulisses de comédie bien est-ce que
la personne quel est le sexe de la
personne en question je sais pas ce que
je sais c'est que c'est une femme je
veux savoir pourquoi on est en train de
marcher là sans avancer parce qu'on est
devant la porte du bloc et il nous reste
encore des répliques
est-ce que la personne en question a été
mise sous péridurale non elle était mise
sous périmés
Michel encore une vanne au cinéaste et
je baisse ta femme quoi attends tu
parles pas de Monique comme ça ta femme
s'appelle Monique non ah bon bonjour
monsieur dame rester assis ne paniquez
pas je suis le chirurgien et je suis en
pleine forme
bon à quelle heure avez-vous perdu les
eaux mademoiselle répondez-moi sans
honte pardon docteur mais c'est pas moi
qui a couché la dame qui est juste là
vous auriez pu très bien faire les zones
[Musique]
plus je me dis que si tu as fait gynéco
c'est parce que tu aimes donner la vie
non c'est parce que j'aime voir de
belles chattes
bon allez c'est parti vous connaissez le
principe on inspire on expire et on
pousse d'accord on inspire on expire et
on pousse allez c'est parti on inspire
on expire on pousse allez on inspire on
expire on pourra continuer
on continue on continue
sur votre ventre madame
et voilà bonjour Maman bonjour ah tu
m'étouffes madame vous avez fait un beau
et grand garçon félicitations vous
auriez pu faire une petite et moi je
suis
comment je m'appelle maman Christelle
mais non mais c'est pas possible ça
c'est un prénom de fille
c'est pas possible je dois me rendre au
bureau
[Musique]
et voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est très très bien vous étiez exposé
de rire
toutes les semaines on a des gens il
fallait me poser cette question il y
avait 20 ans c'est trop tard vous êtes
en retard vous venez quand vous voulez
vous asseoir à côté de moi la semaine
prochaine
alors votre nom de scène avant c'était
c'est vachement compliqué c'était de une
période green rabbit company c'était un
hommage à la royale
je fais toute l'histoire là vous êtes
rencontrés au cours de comédie
d'Isabelle Nanty voilà ensuite vous avez
fait votre pièce au Théâtre des Sablons
à Fontainebleau ouais vous faites juste
ouais d'accord
et puis Farrugia est venu ouais
il a eu le coup de foudre
il a produit la pièce qui a été joué
quand même 250 fois à Paris ensuite il
vous a pris sur cette chaîne Comédie
vous avez fait la grosse émission
l'animateur était jetable mais pas vous
voilà voilà vous l'en voulez pas vous en
fait jouer dans son film trafic
d'influence à farouja
trop bon Ardisson
il est trop content tout ça parce qu'il
a sa petite question à la fin qu'il
adore non je l'ai même pas noté celle-là
j'ai même pas besoin de la noter
quand tu as du pot toi tu es un mec qui
a du pot
pourquoi parce que déjà vous avez
rencontré tous vos amis en même temps
chez Isabelle Nanty premier coup de bol
deuxième coup de bol Farrugia
Fontainebleau
troisième coup de bol Julie Lescaut avec
Véronique
et vous dites et vous dites j'ai de la
chance d'apprendre mon métier avec des
gens aussi généreux que Véronique Genest
et ben
ouais mais c'est vraiment plus et c'est
un métier tourné et d'apprendre les
marques les prendre ses marques au
cinéma et tout ça
c'est difficile et puis le grand noir
aussi apprendre à jouer comme ça et ben
c'est pas évident tous les jours
vous êtes prêt pour l'interview sur la
bouche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon interview sans la bouche vous
connaissez max sur la bouche vous
connaissez
une interview peuvent pas répondre en
parlant donc ils vont être obligés de
mimer leur réponse
vous préférez Hitler ou Staline
il y a un site internet qui s'est créé
pour demander votre retour sur Comédie
vous personnellement vous préfériez
l'époque où vous étiez sur comédie ou
NPA avec Nagui
plutôt comme il dit
[Rires]
vous le trouvez comment dans la NPA
est-ce que ça le fait comme il dit lui
est-ce que vous rêvez je fais comme la
télé est-ce que vous rêvez d'avoir une
émission à vous bonne
réponse combien de temps vous pensez que
j'allais être encore ensemble les Robins
des bois pendant combien d'années
si Jean-Paul si vous deviez signifier
votre attirance pour votre camarade
Marina vous le feriez comment
et vous
est-ce que vous trouvez que les Romains
sont drôles
[Musique]
et vous
et si je n'ai envie de faire un gag là
vous feriez quoi
Serge est-ce que tu peux faire un petit
replay
[Musique]
on attend on va jouer au schmilblick
vous connaissez le schmilblick
[Musique]
le jeu du schmilblick je ne connais rien
je ne regarde jamais la télé
peut-on dire l'hypothèque avec la chose
vous avez jamais entendu parler de ça
vous avez plein de trucs à apprendre
la chose
ah je crois que tu es arrivé à tes fins
un petit peu esclave je vais les vanter
dans les jours avec une feuille de
bananier
bon alors on va jouer au schmilblick
donc vous allez me demander ce qu'est le
schmilblick et je vais vous dire si
c'est ça ou c'est pas ça dites-moi
est-ce que je m'explique et est-ce que
j'ai compris il faut que je rajoute un
mot
est-ce que le schmilblick est un homme
oui
ah vous êtes génial vous
c'est vrai
est-ce que vas-y vas-y est-ce que le
schmilblick a des cheveux oui est-ce que
le schmilblick est présent ici là
est-ce que le schmilblick est un une
femme malgré le fait que ce soit un
homme c'est un homme c'est un homme
homme
des fois par hasard
est-ce que je sais très bien qui c'est
le film
vous connaissez Mouna oui bien sûr elle
a un beau bateau
avec vous
on n'a pas répété mais quand elle veut
vous connaissez des chansons d'Enrico
Macias mon oncle écoutait Henri
commercial quand j'étais toute petite
sans arrêt et puis il y avait une
chanson au Liban qui se répétait que les
Français le connaissent pas c'était quoi
et l'on m'appelle l'Oriental s'ils
connaissent pas les Français
car moi je suis
sentiments et pourtant je ne fais pas
on m'a surnommé
alors vous devez aller chanter à
Constantine vous deviez aller chanter ou
devez aller chanter à cause de je vais
chanter voilà 18 mars et puis partout en
Algérie voilà alors à Constantine Annaba
enfin bonne Tlemcen Tizi Ouzou et Alger
donc Constantine c'est le 18 mars
et Alger c'est le 27 donc c'est une
tournée en Algérie et après on peut dire
qu'après 38 ans donc il y a 38 ans que
vous avez quitté l'Algérie vous êtes
jamais retourné et la boucle est en
quelque sorte bouclée c'est quelque
chose que je n'aurais jamais pas imaginé
en rêve et puis qui viendrait de
m'arriver comme
comme quelque chose de c'est même pas
historique c'est mécanique c'est
messianique c'est assez beau
non
non pas du tout ça m'impressionne pas du
tout je crois que les gens ont une
fausse opinion de la réalité des choses
je pense que tous les gens qui naissent
on devrait leur mettre un gilet par
balles aussi parce que à chaque fois
qu'on est on est condamné à mort toute
façon
quel décodeur
de lui maintenant depuis Enrico
la fête du mouton qu'il a fait du pardon
dans la région musulmane et vous partez
avec 200 autres Juifs d'Algérie qui
était là-bas à l'époque et qui qui je
pars avec 200 enfants d'Algérie de toute
confession et nous allons
reconstruire un pont entre l'Algérie et
la France et un pont qui a été un petit
peu coupé pendant longtemps pendant 40
ans et puis voilà je suis fier d'être le
leader de cette merveilleuse histoire
cette nouvelle page de l'histoire que
j'ai chanté depuis 40 ans alors à la
fin de ce disait quand même que les
conservateurs les islamistes en parlant
de vous en Algérie disait que vous étiez
l'envoyer du gouvernement d'Israël et
que les 200 invités que vous en meniez
avec vous étaient destiné à officialiser
le retour de la communauté juive dans le
pays et que c'était une acceptable alors
d'abord
je suis content de que vous m'avez posé
la question pour mettre au point
beaucoup de choses
premièrement
ces gens-là qui essayent de perturber
mon voyage en Algérie ne réussiront pas
le faire parce que je suis absolument
déterminé parce que ce sont des gens qui
ne représentent rien du tout je sais pas
que je les méprises ou que je les
néglige au contraire
ils ne sont pas représentatifs pour se
permettre de m'interdire d'aller en
Algérie
et maintenant au bout de 40 ans il y a
le peuple algérien dans soi avec une
écrasante majorité qui désire mon retour
en Algérie ou même titre qu'un enfant
d'Algérie et le président Bouteflika et
le seul habilité
alors vous permettez je suis content
qu'il y ait des opposants à ma venue
quelques opposants vous savez combien il
y en a il y en a quatre qui peuvent
détendre sur pas mal mais moi je sais
que il y a 99% d'Algériens dont le
président Bouteflika qui désire ma venue
en Algérie ce qui prouve que l'al
travailler sur le chemin de la
démocratie ça simplement c'est quand
même le FLN de Constantine qui qui s'est
manifestée moi je me suis jamais mêlé de
la politique intérieure de l'Algérie la
seule chose c'est que j'ai toujours
regretté qu'il y ait de la violence en
Algérie je l'ai je l'ai dénoncé et comme
j'ai dénoncé celle qui a existé pendant
la guerre d'indépendance et que je
respecte les morts de tous les de toutes
des deux côtés tout le monde a eu les
mêmes souffrances Enrico je vais pas
vous le bourdon enfin personne ne
me foutra le Bourdon et je le dis sans
aucune polémique et je le dis sans
aucune peur et je le dis je rassure tout
le monde tous les gens mon public mes
proches ma famille qui a peur pour moi
moi j'ai peur pour eux mais moi j'ai pas
peur pour moi et je l'ai rassure tout de
suite parce que je sais que l'action qui
est mené c'est une action positive qui
est dans le but et la finalité c'est la
paix et la fraternité et c'est une page
tourn pour nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants si on continue à
se je veux dire cautionner ce genre de
choses ça veut dire qu'on a on amènera
rien au futur et on amène rien à nos
enfants
écoutez au risque de ma vie je suis prêt
à aller jusqu'au bout je me fous
perdument de ma vie j'en ai rien à
par rapport au symbole que je
représente et si je devais faire marche
arrière je pourrai plus me regarder
devant une glace jamais
[Applaudissements]
alors donc votre histoire commence là
commence à Constantine vous allez
retourner donc au mois de mars rubiskara
première guitare à l'âge de 12 ans et
votre père joue avec Raymond Lewis chez
Crémont tonton Raymond qu'on vous la
comme vous l'appelez et vous sortez ce
disque en hommage tu peux zoomer mon
garçon
voilà vous sortez ce disque en hommage à
vraiment les risques
c'est de la musique arabo andalouse
Maalouf comme on dit un peu c'est pour
ça que je l'ai pas samplé parce que
c'est de la musique qu'on écoute pas
comme ça en 30 secondes ça s'écoute quoi
c'est un mélange de musique classique de
musique folklorique une musique qui est
née à Grenade et à Séville lorsque les
communautés juives et musulmanes
coexistaient ensemble en Espagne et puis
qui ont été obligés d'être chassés par
Isabelle la Catholique en 1492 et a eu
un mouvement
492 un jeudi
Isabelle lacassonne
ma fille ma fille de mon pays dans une
logique de pardon je peux te dire un mot
on a eu une rencontre un promptu donc tu
te souviens peut-être mais tu sais
peut-être pas que c'était moi un jour tu
avais un petit pépin avec une 305
blanche qui est en Twingo
oui j'ai eu un pépin oui c'est vrai j'ai
eu un accident malgré moi avec ma fille
et mes petits-enfants et c'était toi
dans la 300
tu es le roi des tu sais
pourquoi parce que tu as failli tuer des
petits-enfants dans la voiture je suis
moi je m'en fous j'étais je sortais de
boîte j'étais
vraiment toile là
pardon j'en profite maintenant tu es
très chaud tu vas me mettre un pain
alors c'était pas moi alors
non non il est chaud c'était pas moi
mais ça j'ai pas d'humour
je propose que tu racontes l'histoire de
bons pieds Bonneuil pour détendre tout
ce tout le monde
je me rappelle plus de cette histoire le
général qui pète c'est l'histoire que tu
racontes comment tu connais que cette
histoire
je sais tout de suite
à mes petits-enfants
puis l'accident et tout l'enfant bon je
m'excuse
tu m'as bien chauffé
bien donc vous avez commencé votre
carrière à l'âge de 15 ans avec chèque
Raymond Léry ce qu'elle vous rendez
hommage donc moi je vais genre tu vois
le télé auquel vous rendez hommage dans
ce CD vraiment c'est vraiment c'est
l'exemple même de quelqu'un qui était
multi confessionnel puisque son père
était juif sa mère était chrétienne et
lui chantait en arabe donc on peut pas
être plus
œcuménique que lui et vous tombez
amoureux de sa fille Suzie qui deviendra
votre femme alors j'ai préparé plein de
chansons pour vous quels sont jolies les
filles devant
joli les filles de l'amour
ça nous rappelle des bons souvenirs ça
moi aussi je peux vous dire moi aussi
alors quand il a rencontré sa femme en
plus Enrico elle était
le petit nœud comme ça au bout des
nattes et tout est tombé tout de suite
hein mais depuis tout petit depuis la
rue biscarrade
non et là la première fois que quand il
a vu sa femme Suzy pour la première fois
il a eu honte d'avoir des des culottes
courtes c'est la première fois de sa vie
où il a eu honte d'avoir des culottes
quoi première femme ça fait Suzie
dernier chien s'appelait Manix c'est
dans les livres d'histoire
il était beau la comparaison elle me
plaît beaucoup non non c'était pour
c'était des noms que j'ai retenu c'est
pas une comparaison
alors l'Asie
parce que dans le privé on l'appelle ta
race non c'est vrai il connaît tout mais
moi il m'a tué moi il m'a tué
moi je voulais m'excuser après
l'accident et puis j'ai appris des
choses sur sa vie il dort à gauche de
lit à gauche
c'est vrai en plus
la nuit se lève pour manger un peu de
pain avec de l'huile d'olive un peu
continue continue
rappelle-moi des souvenirs
[Rires]
est-ce que tu sais qu'avant de quitter
l'Algérie en 62 quand tout le monde est
parti Enrico était déjà venu en France
quelques temps à Fontainebleau
exactement et c'est la première fois
vous avez rencontré le racisme en fait
c'est le racisme vous l'avez pas
rencontré à Constantine en Algérie là où
vous habitiez vous l'avez rencontré là
le racisme c'est enfin il y avait un peu
de racisme quand même ça existait mais
il était organisé en s'en apercevait pas
tandis que quand je suis arrivé à
Fontainebleau là j'ai rencontré le
racisme parce que j'étais différent
physiquement des autres j'aime pas les
juifs ils vous disaient les types oui il
y en a un qui me disait par exemple
d'ailleurs je vais casser la figure et
puis ça m'a coûté un renvoi il me dit
j'aime pas les Juifs mais mais les
Arabes je les aiment bien parce qu'il
m'avait pris pour un arabe voilà
il m'avait tout de suite édifié sur le
reste et là vous les avez eu c'est que
donc il voulait pas il y avait un club
dans ce que dans ce lycée à
Fontainebleau il y avait un club et
alors il voulait rentrer dans le club et
puis les mecs bon ils le snober un peu
et un jour il y a il y avait une fête du
club et le le décor s'est effondré et
pendant qu'il remontait le décor Enrico
il a joué avec sa guitare et les mecs
ont trouvé ça génial et c'est comme ça
que je suis devenu chanteur et c'est
quand ils ont cassé le décor que j'ai
meublé il a meublé c'est son premier
récital après il disait le mur du lycée
pour aller dans des petits cabarets
bon son point fort c'est jusqu'à ça
c'est vrai
comme ça j'ai pas tellement c'est pas
comme pour chanter
c'est incroyable
et alors donc quand vous avez votre bac
vous retournez en Algérie donc vous
retrouvez Suzy et vous devenez
surveillant dans une école et il
apprenait aux petits arabes il leur
apprenait nos ancêtres les Gauloises
cette fois-ci surréaliste doit dire
comme
ouais
c'est la
valise ou le cercueil quoi
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
quand je repense à ces moments-là c'est
à la suite de l'assassinat de Tonton que
toute la communauté juive et la
Communauté française a décidé de partir
de partir bah écoutez ce qu'on peut
faire sans remuer les vieux souvenirs on
peut quand même écouter la chanson que
petit bout de la chanson vous avez
composé sur le sur le bateau en rentrant
à Marseille j'ai quitté
[Applaudissements]
j'ai quitté ma maison
[Musique]
ma vie ma triste vie
se traîne sans raison
[Musique]
j'ai quitté mon soleil
j'ai quitté ma mère
souvenir se réveille
bien après mon adieu
voilà alors
c'est incroyable 38 ans après d'y
retourner oui et justement il y a des
gens qui m'ont dit mais tu vas tu vas
chanter cette chanson dans tu vas pas
changer les paroles
jamais de la vie j'ai la chanter telle
qu'elle était
c'est ça que je voulais dire je voulais
dire que quand je vais la chanter en
Algérie c'est une chanson que j'ai
jamais pu enlever de mon répertoire
jamais pu enlever de mon cœur j'ai
jamais pu enlever de ma mémoire
et même quand je vais retourner en
Algérie je la rejetterai encore parce
qu'il y a quand même quelque chose qui
est parti de nous mais qu'on va
retrouver pour nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants
[Musique]
ah c'est une femme Mouna
bon alors après moi je vais je vais
raconter l'histoire sinon ah je vois
Christophe de mini tchikena est-ce qu'il
peut rentrer Méline est-ce qu'on peut
faire rentrer Christophe Dominici
maintenant bonsoir venez avec nous
bonsoir
bon vous restez on va arriver à vous
Christophe vous m'en voulez pas je
termine avec mon client précédent et mon
client
donc j'ai terminé l'histoire donc vous
avez Argenteuil vous chantez dans un
cabaret à Pigalle et le dernier jour
c'est pour ça que je tiens à aller au
bout de cette histoire le dernier jour
Enrico a fini dans le cabaret à Pigalle
il a fini ça récital disons et il y a un
coup de téléphone et c'est
Igor Barrère qu'à l'époque faisait cinq
colonnes à la une vous verrez ça dans
les émissions d'Arthur
Igor Barrère qui faisait 5 qu'il appelle
et qui vous demande de venir jouer à
Dieu mon pays pour sa colonel à la Une
vous y allez vous jouer cette chanson
vous la chantez entouré par des par des
pieds-noirs bouleversés et donc là c'est
le succès et j'allais voilà Paris tu
m'as pris dans tes bras souvenez de sa
langue en 62 vous aviez quel âge en 60
62 62 j'avais 3 ans
tu m'as fait dans tes rêves voilà et là
vous faites Olympia et puis depuis vous
l'avez fait combien de fois l'Olympia
16 ou 17 16 ou 17 fois voilà
comme vous êtes justement quelqu'un de
sincère je vais vous faire l'interview
mensonge on ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je surveille ce côté là toi tu
es surveillé l'autre côté ça a bougé non
un max Gallo a un peu bougé
on recommence j'aime pas balancer mais
je le soupçonne d'avoir les chaines
caisse il a une petite crise
où est le pays
c'est compliqué bon euh
alors l'interview mensonge Enrico c'est
très compliqué c'est à moi que ça tombe
est-ce que vous gagnez bien votre vie
non je suis un pauvre
donner de donner dieu vous le rendra
est-ce que vous avez déjà fraudé le fisc
mais oui mais qui n'a pas frodé le film
est-ce que vous êtes toujours catholique
intégriste
toujours mais je suis un dévot mais
alors je suis fidèle tous les dimanches
le Shabbat
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes quand même toujours un peu
extrême droite un peu antisémite quand
même Rico non ah là là ne me parlez pas
de ces gens-là avec leur nez crochu et
tout ça et tout le poney en qui gagne et
tout allez retourner dans votre pays et
surtout pas en Israël
sur la télé
vous vous trouvez comment physiquement
en ce moment un haricot
non je suis très laid c'est mensonge non
vous trouvez très bien en ce moment vous
avez grossi
non mais j'ai blanchi
il parle pas des régimes parce que c'est
son gros problème
c'est la nuit est dans le frigo le pain
avec l'huile d'olive
est-ce que vous fréquentez toujours les
bars américains
toujours je suis tous les soirs moi tous
les soirs tous les soirs je fréquente
ces boîtes tous les soirs et je fus mais
je le cigare et non je suis pas cigare
en vérité je fume le cigarette
c'est terrible c'est terrible avec lui
est-ce que vous êtes plutôt Enrico
plutôt haschich ou plutôt herbe
elle est dure celle-là
disons chez nous on dit ça veut dire ça
vient de ce mot là ça vient du mot
achiche ça veut dire ça veut dire on
aime bien avoir la tête un peu dans les
nuages comme ça entre deux mondes
artificiels donc vous êtes plutôt herbe
en fait dans l'interview je suis
dernière question vous avez peur de
mourir
ah oui j'ai très peur de mourir très
très peur gilet par balle en Algérie pas
gilet par balle
merci bon on est arrivé quand même merci
bonsoir bonsoir pour des amorcer
évidemment c'était pas moi dans la
voiture je pense que j'ai essayé de tuer
ses petits-enfants Laurent c'est deux
secondes après je te jure j'ai tellement
un mauvais souvenir cet accident j'étais
persuadé que c'était toi tu m'as piégé
mais après j'ai compris quand tu m'as
parlé de bon pied bon œil et tout ça toi
tu dois connaître ma fille Josiane ta
fille
Christophe Dominici donc vous mesurez
1m73 vous pesez quoi 80 kilos un peu
plus de 83 83 Le Tellier gauche au Stade
Français dirigé par Max voisini que je
salue ici c'est bien oui
votre look là vos cheveux un peu méché
blond comme ça c'est une idée
c'est pas une idée c'est je trouve que
ça
embellie un petit peu vous trouvez que
ça vous embellie
et vous aimez son sport
vous avez fait des photos avec cher
comment elle est de près
très très bien en fait mais est-ce que
ça se voit non pas du tout ah bon
elle est très très belle pour son âge
donc finalise de la Coupe du monde en 99
tournoi des 6 nations on fait partie de
l'équipe de France qui a battu le Pays
de Galles 3 à 36 le 5 février dernier et
il le dit ouais non attendez et le 19
février donc vous tournez dans vous
jouez dans le tournoi des 6 nations
France - Angleterre et qui sera sur
France 2 je le dis c'est sur France 2
vous coucher de bonne heure là
c'est un peu tard déjà non non ça va
vous avez la permission de quelle heure
en général
et là donc vous jouez pas demain avec le
Stade Français contre où je faisais
dispenser si si je jouais vous jouez
quand même vous fatigue
vous connaissez Bernard la porte le type
du Stade Français qui est entré dans
l'équipe de France
il a dit en parlant de Christophe
affamé les joueurs après les joueurs
vous les affamés des avants et des
arrières vous les enfermez dans un
endroit clou vous mettez un steak au
milieu
c'est lui c'est Dominici qui va se
bouffer
[Musique]
si on fait cette compétition je gagnerai
hein
bon on va voir un petit magnéto
c'est le côté fermé qui a été choisi oh
regardez bien cette action Dominici
formidable 2 3 crochet il semble qu'il
va la laisser d'enculer le rattrape
c'est le regroupement au pied des photos
au revoir cette face de jeu
extraordinaire
l'exploit de Dominici
qui va droit pour fixer qui déborde à
l'extérieur les restes pour nous c'est
bien là les anciennes ou de pieds
par-dessus la défenseur il a pris la
balle
[Applaudissements]
le ici
vous deux le 2000 Bénin Fabienne Galtier
au formidable c'est une belle récompense
pour
ce diable de Christophe Dominici qui
avait amené un essai extraordinaire
c'est un point de plus transformation
qui sera tentée par Christophe la maison
bonne récompense on s'en réjouit pour ce
petit bonhomme à la petit bonhomme plein
de tonicité solide qu'il est Christophe
Dominici
vous êtes un héros pourtant la vie a
commencé d'une façon assez dure pour
vous
à 14 ans vous perdez votre sœur Pascal
dans un accident elle avait 18 ans
c'était un peu votre deuxième maman et
vous dites j'en voulais à la terre
entière ensuite vous enfermez chez vous
vous êtes révolté par cette disparition
et vous commencez à cumuler les
conneries vous avez fait des graphes
conneries
vous avez volé
quoi des mobylettes des bagnoles des
voitures vous conduisez sans permis ça
m'est arrivé vous avez des mauvaises
fréquentations
je sais pas si on peut appeler ça
mauvaise
mais j'avais des copains qui faisaient
ce genre de choses
est-ce qu'il y avait comme cassette dans
le poste je conduis SANS PERMIS vous
conduisez sans permis c'est interdit
pour les femmes en Arabie Saoudite
jamais avoir de permis de conduire sans
permis
jamais j'ai eu le permis alors
un petit peu j'étais passé par une
période difficile et donc j'ai pris des
coups de pied aux fesses qui m'ont fait
avancer qui m'ont fait évoluer vous
dites sans le rugby je serais devenu un
voyou
parce que je trouve ça m'a porté
énormément de choses au niveau de la
solidarité de l'amitié
un moment de ma vie j'en avais
énormément besoin
alors vous avez hésité avec le foot à un
moment c'est à dire qu'en fait vous
hésité avec le foot vous aviez les
qualités vous dites pour être un bon
footballeur
alors je vous posais quelques questions
sur le foot vous allez me dire si on va
voir si vous interview foot le club
champion l'année dernière on souffle pas
Bordeaux
qui est en tête de la D1 aujourd'hui ah
oui il est fort le meilleur buteur cette
année-là actuellement je pense que c'est
il y a très aigu aussi
qui a pris la succession de Courbis à
l'OM
non non Casoni
vous êtes forts
dans dans quel club joue Deschamps
Brésil les buteurs c'est qui Zidane
Zidane petit bravo
[Applaudissements]
mais quand on lui pose des questions sur
le foot il répond c'est bien alors en 94
donc
vous commencez à première division avec
Toulon 97 vous rencontrez la porte
justement et qui vous dit si tu viens à
Paris je ferai de toi un international
et vous rentrez au Stade Français et
aujourd'hui selon un sondage du midi du
Midi Olympique qui est le journal du
rugby vous êtes le joueur préféré des
jeunes
[Musique]
courir ils se sont peut-être identifiés
à moi
c'est possible
mais donc allez au moment où on les a
joué ils étaient considérés comme la
meilleure équipe du monde et ça fait
forcément peur d'affronter la meilleure
équipe du monde
vous êtes à l'origine du premier essai
vous ont marquez un et la France bat les
nouvelles Zélande 43 à 31 c'est la
première fois qu'il se faisait tailler
comme ça enfin moi je suis pas un
spécial du rugby mais c'est quand même
des mecs qu'on a réputation d'être les
plus forts effectivement
mais c'est dur d'expliquer
l'inexplicable puisque à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui je sais pas comment on a
fait pour les battre donc on avait on
devait avoir énormément de chance si on
avait certainement le mérité ce jour-là
c'était un vrai c'est un vrai délire on
a même vu ce jour-là des Anglais à tous
les Can-Am qui chantait la Marseillaise
donc c'est vrai que il vous dites
j'avais l'impression que ma sœur me
regardait dans haut vous avez senti je
sais pas si on peut appeler ça sentir
mais c'est vrai quand on passe aux
personnes qu'on aime elle nous aide
quelquefois
et puis après il y a eu la finale contre
l'Australie mais là vous étiez pourquoi
vous étiez fatigué vous étiez déjà allé
trop loin
je pense qu'ils étaient plus forts et ça
faisait deux ans qui préparait leur
titre de champion du monde et nous on a
préparé une semaine donc le temps n'est
pas du tout le même
non mais je pense qu'ils étaient plus
fort en Orient caché certaines choses si
on aurait été champion du monde donc
c'est bien qu'ils ont gagné c'est bien
qu'on soit souvent vous allez gagner le
tournoi des 6 nations là j'espère
bien on va faire une interview première
fois on baisse la lumière on ne bouge
pas pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien intérêts
votre premier souvenir de votre vie
c'est dur ça
va
non c'est normal
c'est pas très bien
dans une cage d'escalier
les ascenseurs quand on est quand on le
fait pas exprès je veux dire c'est
beaucoup moins drôle votre premier objet
fétiche je peux pas le dire
dans l'ascenseur aussi
vraiment le premier péché
le vol le vol vous souvenez ce que
c'était
c'est le porte-monnaie de votre mère au
début non non il a piqué un ballon
personne ne l'a rattrapé
ces petites voitures je crois
votre premier jour à l'école vous en
souvenez
très difficile
et le premier jour au Stade Français
je me suis demandé ce que je faisais là
quand j'ai eu beaucoup de nouvelles
têtes un nouvel entraîneur en nouvelle
Président je me suis dit j'ai peut-être
pas fait le meilleur choix
le premier idole
Enrico
c'était qui votre première idole
histoire de Madonna
l'histoire quand il créait
une chanson très vous savez ce qu'elle a
dit non
ce qu'on peut le dire sur la télévision
française on peut tout dire dans cette
émission on peut tout dire
alors il se lève il prend le CD il le
jette par la fenêtre en me disant je ne
veux plus jamais entendre parler de
cette femme chez moi
j'ai évacué grâce à toi
Premier Flirt
ça vous a pas laissé un souvenir
impérissable premier trou de nous
appeler
[Rires]
votre émission
la première fois avec une fille vous en
souvenez là oui bon d'accord et avec un
garçon
c'est la grande très très mal passé
vous avez pu recommencer
il va t'amener ses potes tu vas voir
et alors sympathique
tu sens quand même que le cristal salut
combien de filles comme un garçon
[Musique]
trois garçons de filles je pense
tous les jours
première cuite
douloureuse douloureuse pastis oui
impérissable très mauvais
ah bon vous avez plus jamais recommencer
non
rugby certainement je me disais aussi
première extasie
premier million
pas encore pas encore
pour les pas que je vous donne quelques
leçons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme vous avez été très sympathique je
voulais juste vous faire un petit cadeau
c'est le nouvellisme du Stade Français
je sais pas si je vais y arriver
[Applaudissements]
et ça c'est un original ça oui très bien
merci beaucoup j'écouterai en pensant à
vous merci Christophe
à toi le match
bon je vais vous dire où j'étais droit
dans un nouveau
qui
[Musique]
Bruno bonsoir salut vous avez vu Mouna
on vous met que des mecs top à côté de
vous là j'adore les mecs avec une
vous avez l'accent
vous essayez de
Canada les hommes ont des queues comme
ça
[Musique]
donc dans Notre Dame de Paris qui
reprend mardi prochain
au Palais des Congrès
c'est un peu pour ça que vous êtes là
parce que je fais le redémarre à Paris
pour la première semaine et je viens
présenter un spectacle pour parce que
j'ai une carrière solo aussi donc à la
Cigale mais sinon l'aventure francophone
pour moi est terminée
à la Cigale voilà et le 22 à Lyon voilà
la vie de Bruno Pelletier est un enfer
c'est entre le Québec et la France et
entre Notre-Dame de Paris et vos
œuvres personnelles c'est extrêmement
compliqué c'est compliqué je bossais un
peu dire que c'est l'enfer mais en tout
cas c'est c'est le rêve de plusieurs
mais quand on est dedans effectivement
c'est difficile à gérer un moment donné
on y arrive alors votre CD donc
s'appelle d'autres voilà je montre à la
caméra zoom mon garçon
et le single s'appelle loin de chez moi
[Musique]
je
veux
ma lune lentement mais tu es
alors Bruno Pelletier les auteurs sur le
sur le CD c'est plein Mondon coachente
Daniel Lavoie enfin que des gens déjà
connus des gens un peu moins connus
aussi qui sont très connus chez nous
comme Richard Seguin d'Anne
bigores des compositeurs très connus au
Québec j'ai voulu faire un espèce de
pont et de mariage pour cet album là
entre les amis les gens que j'aime avec
qui j'aime travailler d'ici et de chez
nous vous avez droit à un art divi où
mon pauvre on était à la lumière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pensez à quoi là je me demande qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire
j'ai pas compris ce que vous avez dit
que je sais pas un art review un ordre
d'interview qui s'appelle l'art divio
d'accord
la dernière chose que vous faites avant
de vous coucher
banalement je lis un livre tout le temps
pour essayer de me vider l'esprit un peu
relaxer
le matin quand vous regardez dans la
glace vous vous dites quoi
ça passe ça ça passe ça passe ça passe
ça veut dire
quoi en vous si vous avez une baguette
magique la voisine à mon avis
j'aime pas
j'aurais aimé bof c'était adolescent
j'étais un peu complexe avec ça avec les
années ça passe ça aussi mais peut-être
être plus grand un peu plus grand je
mesure
spécial Québec et on avait pris un
traducteurs
tout de suite au fur et à mesure
deux pièces 7 la phrase que vous
supportez pas d'entendre c'est quoi cet
accent de merde
ce que les femmes préfèrent chez vous je
viens de vous le dire
ça c'est moche avec les années j'essaie
de le contrôler tu contrôles bien
Xavier le choix sur une île déserte
faire l'amour avec une fille très moche
ou un mec très beau
[Rires]
tout de suite
pas du tout ni l'un ni là
d'abord pourquoi je partirai sur une île
déserte
non je pense que je vais rester tout
seul dans mon coin puis je peux enlever
quand on a pas le choix
si on n'a pas le choix
qu'est-ce que vous feriez si vous restez
24 heures à vivre
le coiffeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si c'était à refaire votre vie vous
changeriez quoi rien du tout non rien
vous changerez quoi Mouna
parce qu'ils sont nés ils ont vécu dans
des pays libres moi j'aurais voulu être
chanteuse et danseuse dans un
cabaretites chez nous absolument
refaire ma vie c'est ce que je serai les
milliardaires elle veut faire
strip-teaseuse c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
alors maintenant attention
maintenant on arrive au blind test Max
Gallo
[Musique]
test on va écouter des chansons il faut
reconnaître dès le début l'interprète et
le donner le titre de la chanson
pour vous Mouna et pour toi Enrico nous
avons fait un blind test oriental Didier
premier morsure
[Applaudissements]
il s'appelle comment
[Musique]
tu t'appelles comment
Jonathan tu es venu une star au top
ça s'appelle parisien du Nord
[Musique]
on continue Didier
un peu
[Musique]
du temps
attention attention c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué le morceau suivant est
beaucoup plus compliqué
je vois
Mustapha Mustapha
attends
qu'est-ce qui se passe
je vais être une star oui
[Musique]
et voilà Enrico Macias est venu une star
le pied de Rico le petit nerico et il
est devenu une star ce soir
[Musique]
je t'aime
bravo
[Musique]
ancien DJ c'est normal en même temps
Rachid Taha
ya et dernier morceau il faut me les
trois internes de rothing
[Musique]
Notre Dame de Paris Bruno Pelletier
je t'aime je l'aime encore
[Musique]
j'ai dit les deux premiers
et maintenant viens une épreuve
particulièrement difficile Max Gallo
particulièrement difficile c'est le vrai
jeu de la vraie vérité
est-ce que vous connaissez
connaissez l'héritée qui s'appelle en
fait tout le monde à vous dire vous
pouvez poser Mouna à n'importe qui
autour de cette table la question que
vous voulez et les autres invités sont
obligés d'y répondre mais tout le monde
peut faire ça toi aussi Bruno toi aussi
Enrico toi aussi Jean-Paul toi aussi
Marina toi aussi Laurent
qui commence
tiens-moi je vais commencer
Bruno je voudrais savoir combien de
temps il faut pour avoir une grande
queue comme ça
c'était la question
ça tourne autour de ça c'est 17 ans
environ
à ton avis que pense ta famille de tes
nouvelles lunettes
je crois que c'est des questions
fondamentales je vais te dire j'ai fait
un triomphe avec ses lunettes pourquoi
parce que j'en avais d'autres avant pour
lire c'était une catastrophe tout le
monde me disait mais enlève ses lunettes
c'est horrible et tout j'ai pas de faire
de la peine mais moi je fais un petit
sondage tu as vu j'avais des infos ils
le disent pas pour pas te faire de peine
mais il les trouve pas terrible
Simon qui n'a pas voulu que je mène
à ta femme elle te dira ta race tes
lunettes
vous avez une question à poser Jean-Paul
à quelqu'un ici autour de cette table à
vous on peut ou pas
c'est une question à vous poser
vous faites sérieux on a le droit on
fait ce qu'on peut être ou sérieux ou
pas sérieux tout est possible je voulais
savoir si vous êtes toujours royaliste
et qu'est-ce que vous dites aux gens qui
qui disent que du royalisme à l'extrême
droite la passerelle est très étroite je
leur dis qu'il confondent ils croient
que le royaliste c'est un parti
politique alors que c'est un système de
gouvernement déjà et que par exemple un
Espagne il y a des monarchistes de
gauche des monarchistes de droite en
Angleterre des monarchistes de gauche et
des monarchistes de droite c'est pas un
parti politique la Monarchie c'est un
système de gouvernement et c'est vrai
qu'en France il y a quelqu'un qui
s'appelait Charles Moras qui a fait
beaucoup de mal à la monarchie en
l'identifiant à l'extrême droite voilà
ce que je dis bravo je suis très content
au Maroc tu m'énergie
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous aimez les femmes ou les
hommes
il est de notoriété publique que je
n'aime que les hommes
tout le monde le sait tu l'as parce que
tu viens l'étranger tu ne sais pas mais
mon signe astrologique
d'une chose qui me tient à cœur parce
que je m'occupe d'une association qui
achète des chaînes paralysées et comme
tu es pété de thunes je vais t'extorquer
un chèque
d'où te vient ce sens de la fête comme
ça
[Applaudissements]
je vous montre tout ce qui a à acheter
et c'est du mauvais
donc les Robins des bois sont des cons
ça c'est les sketchs de comédie et si
c'est tout comme celui qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure je pense que vous allez en
vendre
il est vachement bien Bruno Pelletier
donc il y a le single loin de chez moi
voilà et le CD donc il s'appelle
d'autres rives
voilà Enrico
chez cremont hommage etc le 4 et le 5
mars et ensuite Constantine de 18 mars
voilà ça c'est pour notre ami qui est
parti c'est life ISO strong c'est
l'hymne du Stade Français
puis aussi vous parler de du livre de
Peggy boucher qu'on a reçu ici qui
s'appelle ma victoire sur l'Atlantique
c'est que vous connaissez Peggy boucher
[Musique]
vie extraordinaire
Alpha Blondy se dit s'appelle
Journaliste en Danger il est vendu au
profit de par reporter sans frontières
pour les journalistes en danger vous
savez qu'il y a des tas de journalistes
chaque année il y a 36 journalistes qui
ont été tués en 99 et donc c'est un
disque qui est vendu au profil des gens
ils s'envolveurs et Max Gallo le premier
club top à la déconne
le premier tome de bleu blanc rouge qui
s'appelle Mariella et le prochain son
avril c'est ça ça vous devriez le lire
vous c'est passionnant bah oui le soir
en rentrant au Québec
je peux annoncer quelque chose
c'est que si jamais on ne peut pas venir
me voir à l'Olympia le 4 et le 5 mars
avant ma tournée en Algérie ils peuvent
faire un petit tour à Lyon au Palais des
Congrès
vous êtes aussi à Lyon
le 21 et au Transbordeur à Lyon le 22
Bruno Pelletier voilà merci heureusement
que je suis là Anne de pétrini Canal+
comédie Laurent Baffie Europe 2 c'était
tout le monde en parle rendez-vous la
semaine prochaine
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu